hey leute ich hatte gerade mal wieder
e-mails bock auf happy wales ich habe
zwar noch ein paar folgen auf lager
allerdings habe ich mir gedacht okay ich
hab noch eine folge auf lager ich
brauche schon wieder neue aber ich habe
total bock gerade dieses spiel zu
spielen das ist das erste let's play wo
ich mir richtig sagt soko habe ich jetzt
richtig bock so richtig viel aufzunehmen
na ja wir haben ja letztes mal dieses
super mario level gespielt
ich würde sagen da wir da nicht weiter
gekommen sind probieren wenn man dieses
wird kommen beim play now und was ich
euch mal eben fragen wollte kann man
sich dieses spiel in wie runterladen
beziehungsweise gibt es andere
naja was soll ich sagen mein gott oh
mein gott
ich glaube das war falsch kann man sich
dieser spiele herunterladen weil ich
habe bei anderen leuten gesehen dass die
immer wählen können zwischen anderen
leuten und halt so ganz viele andere
features die ich hier noch nie zu
gesicht bekommen habe ich mit dem ding
überhaupt spricht einfach nur das
gleichgewicht halten beziehungsweise
schauen noch nicht langsamer oder
schneller mal liegt doch wirkliche warum
interessant so also schreibt mir einfach
in die kommentare
ob man sich das spiel irgendwo in
downloaden ach so jetzt funktioniert das
auch okay jetzt kann man ja auch
charakter wählen das ist sehr schön das
wusste ich nicht
ich würde sagen wenn ihr davon war ja am
anfang ihr museum ein gott pokemon
gemacht wieder so ein punkt mannheim
[Musik]
naja ich glaube das war falsch zur e3
als jupiter show natürlich glaube jetzt
müssen wir aufpassen
oh mein gott oh mein gott hat sich frau
gesehen hat
ok bringt wir sehen uns mehr ich wie na
ja schon übel warte kann ich nicht mal
eben so hier den umfang auch egal so ey
du hast ein bisschen milch verloren naja
also jetzt wirklich milch jetzt nicht
dass ich was falsches denkt hier kleine
perversling hatte ich glaube ich muss
ein bisschen weiter vorfahren kann dabei
der mann ja man ich hoffe dass auch
verdammt lasst mich doch los blöde kuh
nördlingen es hier eigentlich ja sehr
schön
der arme ist zwar weg aber den brauch
war ähnlich hauptaufgaben die milch noch
dabei die take a
ach das ist wie heißt es nochmal the
shock marketing entwickelt profis kamen
oh uh oh mein gott ist das destination
'als mit der stroke 32 naja egal wer es
geschafft so ich es wird eng auf jeden
fall ob wieder schaffen oder kommt unser
arm los los los los hat liege hey komm
unser einkommen kommt uns haben doch
irgendwann ja da kommt als wurde in dem
wir doch mal mit hier kann mir zuhause
schönen dingen schmeißen nach sehr schön
alle körperteile dabei ich habe mal
lieber olympia final showdown
ich war gerade mal nicht ich bremse
melliger psychisch nicht irgendwie was
war das denn psychische powers um
youtube hey so kann ich jetzt irgendwie
mal hier raus es wäre ganz schön lustig
schaffst du schaffst das mädel team
starts to play the very best of cancer
auf deutsch
ja mein gott wir haben es geschafft und
zwei minuten to expect many als bisher
läuft echt besser so spiel 748 auch
keine ahnung in love story wollen wir
einfach mal näher kommen wir nehmen mal
mit dem vater mit seinem kind
sorry der woche problemlos the level
place weight im moment and then try
again ja interessant da sieht man wieder
dass hier allgemeinen dieser website
noch nicht so stabil läuft ich versuche
dass man jetzt einfach jetzt müsste es
aber eigentlich klappen
ja ja und los geht's die mit seinem kind
huhu huhu kind schon wieder verlor
das war unser kind so ab weiter hier
drei vor
deswegen denkt sich weiter interessant
was die you love me do uh oh uh oh ich
glaube es geht wirklich meine liebe
story aber schnell weiter hilfe
ich habe die platten egal ich habe mit
den platten in mainz gilt schaffe ich
das auch so los los los vfa huber muss
ich noch ein bisschen das gleichgewicht
halten oder sein team in dem überall
neues level habe ich keinen bock mehr
drauf das ist blöd okay außerdem der
name ist auch ziemlich doof café das hat
doch eine relativ gute bewertung
nehmen wir mal den alten oper können wir
nehmen hier total.com
los geht's ich glaube das ist eine
verfolgungsjagd wie cool das ist das
dingen sie zum zum mitregieren
[Musik]
oder dass da hat es gerade gelegt das
lag nicht an mir das spiel okay ich bin
gott neben beim rendern von 11 minecraft
parts auf einmal aber interessant
interessant
äußerst interessant aber egal wir
schaffen mann ich wollte so nah so schön
cool geschafft das war ja das war
einfach also ich glaube haben am anfang
wirklich so die schwierigsten level
gespielt nordpol rasch also ich weiß
dass nordpol nordpol heißt und rasch
heißt irgendwie schneller durch oder so
jetzt wenn wir sonst wahrscheinlich
allen was bringt denn jetzt wenn ich
hier die ganze zeit dann kann ich
wahrscheinlich liegen
[Gelächter]
interessant ich verstehe das nicht okay
wir spielen anderes von daher ich werde
das e vornehmen weil ich habe jetzt hier
so was von vielen levels zur auswahl
da können wir ein bisschen welcome you
got to survive da können wir ein
bisschen ja ich will dich sagen
vorsichtiger ich würde eher sagen jedes
level immer so ein bisschen an spielen
wenn wir es wenn wir sofort am anfang
gut sind beziehungsweise schaffen
deshalb alles in ordnung nur wenn wir es
wenn wir halt wissen okay wir schaffen
das nicht dann lassen wir das einfach
und bisher läuft sehr relativ gut
ja das zum thema ist läuft bisher
relativ gut
egal jetzt müssen wir es aber doch
eigentlich schaffen bevor hin eigentlich
nichts gemacht außer man das
gleichgewicht gehalten und eigentlich
dürfte dann die komplette engine jetzt
nicht anders reagieren so hervor hier
kommen wir schaffen das auch so sehr
schön
hallo war starb müssen doch wohl das ist
das darf doch nicht wahr sein jetzt
hapert es an dem staat allein anderem
starb ich glaube es nicht
ach so malter wie geil
am besten alle leute die mal kurz
zurückspulen
es war schon eine geile szene gerade wo
ich schon sagen ach ja diese ist einfach
so zum totlachen
das kann man echt immerhin mal wieder
spielen na ja auch weiter geht es hier
ja fall lacht das ist doch eklig was da
gerade abgeht so diesmal werde ich es
aber schaffen höchstwahrscheinlich epic
doha nach werden das kind verloren
nicht so schön mit einer türkin
erwartete aber ohne das kind zu
erleichtern schafften den sprung der
sofort und nehmen keinen fall mit dann
schaffen wir das hier geschafft aha guck
mal unser körper ist mit unserem beinen
verbunden durch einen damm
naja ok so weiter geht es hier ja la la
la la ach so und was ich von euch möchte
schreibt bitte in die kommentare wollt
ihr täglich einen part oder wollte
lieber so ab und zu mal bat weil
leute meinten macht bitte nicht täglich
parts weil dann verliert das ganze an
wert dann freut man sich lieber dass
mein gott oh mein gott
also ich könnte natürlich täglichen
fahrt machen wenn ihr das wollt wenn ich
ist mir das auch recht also müsst ihr
einfach in die kommentare schreiben
politiker täglichen part wollt oder
lieber sagt so hast du alle 34 tag immer
ein so nicht dass das so überhand
gewinnt auf seinem kanal ton ist das
kommt auch an ich weiß noch nicht ob ich
das projekt vielleicht noch 100 wenden
werde ich weiß es nicht
bei minecraft bin ich ja nun auch schon
also ich hab schon 26 alter das darf
nicht wahr sein
schon 26 putts aufgenommen nein nein
anna sehr schön waha who can be hard to
hh
sehr schön ach verdammt aa ist das nicht
schön so was ja das fahrrad dreht sich
dann noch rhein nahe kommt so von vorne
also das ist ein level wo ich möchte ich
sagen würde komm ich holz auf ich
schaffe das ähnlich vor allem wackelt
aber das ist gerade ich habe das gefühl
dass ich das jeden moment schaffen werde
und dann ist das wieder so ein ehrgeiz
und man sich sagt kommt diesmal schaffte
es aber los mein gott wie kann ich die
bitte nach unten hin
guckt euch mal den kopf von mir wachsen
dann noch ein stückchen hier asa erstmal
schön nochmal ein paar liegestützen
falsch rum
vor allem interessant dass das kind
unter uns lag als wir die gegner stützen
vollzogen haben
das ist auch interessant
wieso explodiert unser fahrrad und das
genauso wie in saints row da gibt es
eine szene da fährt man mit der kutsche
und auf einem explodiert die kutsche und
das hat gerade ganz schön aber das liegt
ja im internet sondern das liegt daran
dass ich gerade andere minecraft
fahrzeug ich wollte eigentlich nein ich
werde keine termine mehr in den letzten
rennen perfekt perfekt so weitergeht
hier optisch und oh mein gott
egal weiter so die axt und so kam
eigentlich noch nie in die quere und
diese kugel ein porno nie mein gott das
kind schießen wir einfach noch mehr
pfeile in den arsch ich komme da hinten
hat sich noch weiter ich glaube ich
sollte man taktische vorgehen und dann
könnt ihr das vielleicht auch was werden
so erstmal hier warten also hier dass es
sich hier kann mir nichts passieren so
dass mit der kugel schaffen wir hier
kann ich auch nichts passieren außerdem
gibt uns den hetzern extreme linke
politik habe ich auch noch nichts von
der tat noch das bein
jetzt ist es zu spät
so haben wir ein anderes level das war
glaube ich gerade ja der zehn wm tag das
ist ja auch ganz cool aus hohoho ach so
ach so dmx ja so weiterfahren und hab
dann hier her
hopp ich würde es gern springen aber
naja wenn ag ist also bisher ist noch
nicht so schwer
[Musik]
ein cooler looping werden falls schild
für das kind mit anzusehen jetzt stufen
müssen wir hier also bisher wirklich
nichts gemacht hat nicht mehr ich halte
gerade ein bisschen das leichtgewicht
aber mehr auch nicht
33 von 36 sekunden sehr schön ok
existiere das war jetzt relativ einfach
wieder dann lenas lied bridge das hätte
ich auch interessant dann einfach so
richtig richtig schnell war geil so
weiter geht so ich dachte jetzt kommen
wir über all diese teile und weiter
geht's dir her darüber gesamt sieht ein
bisschen aus wie die golden gate bridge
war bisher erst wirklich noch nicht so
schwer
ehrlich gesagt kein bisschen heaven
verschafft den job da nicht auch so
wahrscheinlich welche unter muss
interesse so weiter gehe jetzt das kind
heimische verloren aber das ist egal
denn ich habe es geschafft
sehr schön exakt uhr und weiter geht's
sowas werden wir jetzt nicht zu spielen
das ist die frage
das sind hier gern aus also was soll ich
hier machen bitte vielleicht zu ach so
ja das ist interessant aus genau so muss
es sein
hu ein fast raus wahrscheinlich geht es
darum dass man heraus fallen sollte